[Music]
ray is in miami hi ray welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hey what's going on dave nice to meet
you brother you too man how can we help
um i'm in dire straits um i'm a
registered nurse
my wife and i just recently had a set of
five-month-old twins i have a
five-year-old
um and she just recently lost her job
because of obviously this coded
situation
and the only thing she's ever asked me
in her life is to have a house
we are highly in debt and i'm never
going to be able to give that to her the
way things are going
but i have about eight thousand dollars
right now in credit card debt
and interest rates are all above you
know 20
why because i did bankruptcy about 10
years ago and um
i'm trying to get back on track and
somehow i'm getting back into this
that because of you know covet and the
twins and all that
so my question to you is with these
credit card
debt that i do have accumulated should
you think that i just
close out these credit cards don't even
think about them pretend that they're
not their meaning i don't you know use
them but i still pay them back
because i feel like as these accounts
are open
i'm scared i'm gonna keep using them
because we are headed down a really
you know vicious path right now with
this
yeah how old are you i'm 37 sir
how old are the twins
2020 has been a big year 2020 has been a
very very big year
my my five year old actually just
started school she has developmentally
delayed problems also so
she has to be home with all three of
these kids and you know we were living
on two incomes
but now it's just me and as a registered
nurse i don't know if you know the
salary but it's
not great not enough okay
well it's it i can hear the fear in your
voice
um and um all that all that means is
all that means is that you're a good dad
and you want to do the right thing for
your family
and you don't know exactly how to do it
it scares you and that means you're a
good man
so um thank you sir we're gonna help you
i want you to go through
you and your wife i want you to go
through our class
i'm gonna give you a one-year membership
to ramsey plus
which gives you access to everything
financial peace university
um it puts you into the every dollar
budget and you and your wife both of you
are to go through this if i give it to
you free you both have to do it okay
you know absolutely we're both on board
with this we're both okay
now then the second thing is
one of the things you're going to get
out of that is that we quit using credit
cards completely
and you cannot close an account
technically
while you still have debt on it they're
not going to close it out till you pay
it off
but you can you can definitely get out
the credit cards and have a symbolic
closure tonight
with your wife after the kids go to bed
get the scissors out light a candle and
have plastic surgery
a nurse knows how to do that right at
the table right yeah
yeah chop those puppies up and yeah you
quit using them you never use them
they cannot be a crutch and here's the
good news
you are the answer to your problem
uh the bad news is you
are the problem yes sir that's true at
my house and that's true at john's house
so covet didn't cause it the twins
didn't cause it
you guys were irresponsible disorganized
out of control freaks before both of
those things happened right
yes sir that's gonna be 100
all right so we get the mirror out we go
okay you are the solution
and you were the problem that's what i
did at my house when i went broke dude
and i was 28 and i had a brand new baby
named rachel
and i was scared like i hear in your
voice so i'm not picking
on you i'm just loving you all right no
no i i need a wake-up call man
so you know you already have the wake-up
call for you call me i'm just confirming
but the deal is i don't want you i don't
use language where you blame
covet or you blame the coming of the
twins or something
you guys were a mess before this just
exposed it
and warren buffett says you can tell
who's skinny dipping when the tide goes
out
and so that's what happened here okay
you just exposed you know when
when you stress test stupid it comes up
stupid and that's what's happened
your stupid that you were doing got
stress tested that's what happened to me
too dude
that's exactly what happened i was
dumber than you i did it with a lot of
zeros on the end and i went completely
belly up you're gonna make it
oh no i have a lot of zeros
well i'm talking like seven figures of
them but anyway the uh
so you're gonna do great and you're
gonna be able to turn this completely
around and um there's something that
happens when someone reaches that point
that they're ready isn't it
i i've been there too i've been there
too my little boy
your daughter was rachel my little boy
was hank and i remember that frozen
moment
thinking what have i done i i only had
six zeros but it was a lot and it felt
like
the whole house was sitting on my back
yeah and i've i've got one job on planet
earth which is to love my wife and one
job on planet which is to love that kid
and i had shackled us to so many
different concrete
blocks and throwing them into the lake
man was just struggling to tread water
right yeah
and the other good news ray is is that
your registered nurse
that's not a curse that's a blessing you
will always have work
and if you want extra work you can
always find extra
work and if you're not being paid well
you need to probably look for a new
employer because you can get paid well
as a registered nurse you can make some
money
and so uh and you can work more than
you're working and
beat your way through this since you're
down to one income and so
you're gonna make it you're gonna turn
this around you're gonna be doing a
debt-free scream someday here on this
show
you're gonna turn the whole process
upside down i'm proud of you you're
gonna make it hold on
kelly's going to pick up and get you all
signed up for this whole thing